[Music]
morning thanks everybody so today I'm
Thomas I'm a little scientist with
quantum black and today I'd like to talk
about Bayesian optimization and in
particular I want to talk about Bayesian
optimization and how can how can be
applied in your day to day work and
really I want to get to sort of two
things across today like one give it a
little bit of an overview and some
intuition around this around these sort
of algorithms and how they work and
second give you more of a practical view
as well so like really okay if you were
going to go to work to going to work on
Monday again just so you could like
start applying these kind of methods and
see if you get some some cool results
with that and so these are these are
going to be my two my two points for
today so I'll start with the algorithm
and then at the end of the talk we'll
talk a little bit about the practical
aspects with how you would do it and how
you would pull it off in Python yourself
or whatever take very very brief Oh give
you a very very brief overview of all
different different frameworks that are
already out there in case you don't want
to code up your own implementation but
just to sort of painted some general
session yeah there's a setting where in
I think roughly the modeling workflow
with its scientists you can sort of
split it up in these three part and this
is like a simplified view right because
I'm sort of ignoring at the big part
that comes before this what the future
engineering the left side where you fall
away try to get in the data or you try
to wrangle the data where you try to
formulate the questions you want to
answer the policies is always kind of
stuff we're sort of like ignoring that
today treating that it's fixed and I
really want to talk a little bit more
about the model selection part right so
we already have the data we already
engineered a bunch of features for the
core model we're trying to build we've
maybe already done some kind of future
selection some prior filtering or
anything like this and really what we
want to do now is okay we have data we
have a target a target variable and we
want to try to estimate turn a model
that data in the best way best way
possible and
and they invasion optimizations with
algorithms I'm going to talk about today
this is like it's one instance of a
class of algorithms that you can use to
do this this kind of work in general
vation vation optimization bayesian
optimization is much more general than
just this you can actually use it to
optimize any arbitrary blackbox function
but folks this talk is really ok it's
more of like it it's more applied
setting where it's because it's equal to
you as a data scientist so in jet so
we're in this model selection sort of
real so usually just just again to make
sure we're all on the same page right
typically what we try to do here is we
have some kind of performance metric F
that's based on some kind of model or
learner m and usually this performance
metrics we estimated on some kind of
holdout set right like we trained or
classifier or classifier or or model on
the training set and we want to see how
well it does on data that we've never
seen before and typically typically the
model we're trying to learn on the data
it has some kind of hyper parameter
high parameters that we can't estimate
from the data so we need to sort of
specify them ourselves so one example
for a classification problem for example
could be that your model M is some kind
of support vector machine and as you may
remain a support vector machine s or a
bunch of hyper parameter so you might
need to specify maybe the kernel of the
support vector machine or maybe the
regularization parameter
maybe the kernel actually has hyper
parameters as well so you need to
specify them and and bait and what I
want to talk about today is ok how can
we sort of choose these hyperparameters
in a more in a system map in a
systematic way and again so we have the
model and we have some kind of
performance metric rights we want to
optimize so in the case of
classification for example you could
talk about ok I want to maximize the
area under the curve on an outer on test
set
so yeah this is our general setting we
have to perform its function f I learn
em this performance function because it
depends on the model and the model
depends on the hyperparameters really we
can say or out of out-of-sample
performance it really depends on like
how we choose the hyper parameters over
of of our model and again it is all
conditional on the data we have right so
I specified it here but I'm going to
drop that I'm not going to mention that
dependency again and again it's
specified on the it's condition on the
training data so typically at least what
I've been doing in the past is and I
think what most data scientists actually
do in the day-to-day work is when they
when it come into when they do over the
situation like this is they use
something like manual grid search so
what is what is manual grid search what
I've shown here is a lost surface of a
support vector machine
I posted it as a function of two
variables right so I'm looking at a
sports vector machine with a radio based
radio basis kernel so that's - and the
most important part for this if you
don't know what this is is okay we have
a model it depends on two parameters a
parameter gamma focus on the y-axis and
a parameter C on the on the x-axis and
and what it shows is just is the
out-of-sample it's it's the area under
the curve on a test step and higher
values of the air of the area under the
curve or better so we want to try and
maximize this value and higher values
correspond with better and those values
correspond to do so
when you talk about manual grid search
which people do it okay let's just like
let's just build a grid of all of
possible values of our parameters and
evaluate our out of out-of-sample
performance for every epoch combination
of those parameters so here the stars
are basically our grid points in its
plot so we we built a grid and we
evaluate the loss function for every
possible star in this figure I mean this
works right like you basically
basically sampling your your your
performance function so if you do this
you get a you get a good idea of what it
looks like and then you can take just
the point of corresponds to a maximum
value the problem is that this can be
problematic in in two ways one is that
maybe it takes very long time to
actually get a sample of your
performance function so in this
particular case this took baby to three
seconds right to get what will grow on
top of the star but I guess in more
typical examples it can take maybe in
the order of minutes maybe on the order
of hours or sometimes even days if you
change really really big models on
really big data sets right so in those
cases this might actually not be a
feasible approach and the other downside
of this approach is that in higher
dimensions this becomes more and more
infeasible thanks due to thanks to the
curse of dimensionality so the number of
grid points you can build sort of
increases exponentially with the
dimension of your hyper parameter space
so these are two problems right so
basically this thing or this this
approach manual grid search it works
well in simple settings so what can you
do what else what else can you do right
so another another approach from manual
grid search is something called random
grid search and I think maybe some some
of you have read this paper I think it
did so I think it was a paper by venture
written in the context of like these
very deep neural networks which has a
very high dimensional hyper parameter
space and there the author of the office
of that paper basically argued that
especially in high dimensional settings
you need two random bits which is a
better way of of trying to find the best
value compared to that just manually
trying to evaluate all the points so
those of you who don't know around grid
search is by the way it's just again you
have this loss service and what you do
is you just randomly choose points and
evaluate the your performance functions
for for those randomly generated
settings but it feels a bit stupid like
hours I think it was a couple of months
ago and I was trying and I was trying to
build a model on some kind of dataset
and I was doing it and is this felt
really unsatisfactory because yeah I'm
just like I'm just hoping to get lucky
right I'm just
hoping to if you look at this part I'm
just hoping that I sort of sort of
randomly get to do this the space of
good performance and there's no
guarantee of us actually reaching that
region of good performance so I was
asking myself okay if there is a way
that we can do this better like because
preferably if you look at this right if
you look at this plots with evaluated
four points here if you if you look at
this I can sort of see okay in the top
plot or the top part of the plot you see
okay I've now made two points there but
I get relatively low performance I can
get a nice you've around point five
point six years whereas if I go lower in
the plot I actually get better
performance so preferably I would like
if I were to do this in an automatic way
I would like on my algorithm to sort of
see okay hey you know here yeah here
there are actually low values of here we
don't actually perform as well so an NSC
below I actually perform a lot better so
I get I get I sort of want to steer my
algorithm into that region of data
performance that's that's something
that's to me making two intuitive a lot
of sense right you want to steer your
algorithm into a region where you get
better performance it means you're
basically sampling in a more efficient
way so I was willing okay how can I do
this right and one way of doing this is
through Bayesian optimization and it's
based optimization is a is an instance
it's a specific type of algorithms that
falls into a wider class of what's
called sequential model based
optimization algorithms and what this
means
it was very fancy term right with what
it means is it's just like we have a
performance function and we are trying
to build what we're going to do is we're
building some kind of probability model
for that loss function that enables us
to say okay we've just seen these values
now we can sort of update our belief of
where good values of the performance are
let's fear our algorithm into that
direction of better performance and this
is what sequential model based
algorithms try to do they build a model
of the performance function and
sequentially you try to move into that
region of data performance now I don't
what I'm not trying to do here is to say
that you should always use Bayesian
optimization or that it's like a silver
bullet that will always work for you
doing this is only really beneficial in
certain in certain situations especially
because like I said in Bayesian
optimization we're trying to build a
return we're building it probably a
probabilistic model over or lost surface
and building that probability model
introduces computational overhead
because we need to update our beliefs do
a lot do a lot do some computation so it
introduced an X introduces extra
overhead an extra complexity in our
overall pipeline
so really boom Bayesian optimization
only makes sense if you if you have a
very very very high dimensional hyper
parameter space or if it is very
competition very very expensive to
evaluate the the out-of-sample
performance because let's say the other
sample performance takes on the order
maybe takes an hour to evaluate right
for what for one value of theta here
then it's actually not so bad if you
spend two minutes trying to update your
beliefs so that the next time you spent
another hour trying to compute this
thing that you get a better guess right
so in these kind of settings it makes
sense to to think about the gay about
smarter way smarter ways right in
simpler setting so if you think back
about this law service I just shows you
guys a couple of slides back in that
particular setting and this is probably
not the most efficient way of doing it
right
then you should then you can just do a
manual grid search over the whole
parameter space but in other settings
especially in these two settings this
could be beneficial and I think these
methods these Bayesian optimization
algorithms they've been especially
useful in the context of very deep
neural networks and it also things these
these work really well
now this is sort of like the sort of the
general overview of the problems we the
problem the setting we are in the
problems we are dealing with so now I
want to talk a little bit about about
this Bayesian optimization algorithm and
build up some some kind of intuition
around this without trying to go too
much into the details of the
mathematical mathematics behind the this
algorithm so this this Bayesian
optimization algorithm you can sort of
divide it in three three steps usually
you sort of seed your your algorithm
with a couple of hand picks or randomly
evaluated points so usually you already
have like some values of the performance
function so what you do you use those
values first to build a belief of the of
the performance function you are having
once you have that the least you know
you now know okay I said let's now you
have updated you believe and now you
know you sort of have an idea of okay in
this particular region there I have
higher performance in this particular
region I have lower performance here I
haven't evaluates a lot of points yet so
maybe it might be worthwhile to try and
evaluate some points there as well so
what we then do given that belief so
given given our updated belief and
bottom we are going to try and pick a
new a new value for the high parameters
to evaluate and the way we do that is is
we're going to maximize some kind of
like a utility function or over this
belief that we're having I want you've
done that you get a new you get a new
potential you get a new candidate for
you for your hyperparameters and then
you can go on and on and on usually you
go on and on until usually specify a
number of iterations you do this for or
you can maybe you can also build like
your method some kind of hand classes
criterion right maybe the performance
function is to go the consecutive
differences in the performance functions
become sufficiently small then you can
say okay that's just okay
I've reached some kind of optimum let's
just stop it let's just stop it there so
this is the general overview of the of
the algorithm now I'll go into each of
the three three steps in more detail now
and in general I just want to say that
okay this is the Bayesian optimization
algorithm
but in the general class of sequential
model based algorithms I was talking
about they follow a very similar pattern
to this usually you you have a you have
a performance function you want to try
and update you want to try and build a
probability model overall know you want
to build some kind of model over its
function then you go maximum utility
over that model you build and then you
evaluate either its programs function
for your new your new theta and usually
and the way in which these algorithms
usually differ is in how you build the
actual model of your performance
function but now we'll focus we'll focus
first on this and what we do invasion
optimization is we use something called
Gaussian processes to actually model the
model of a performance function and why
we call and why the reason why we call
this particular algorithm evasion
optimization algorithm is that we said
we use we use them we use ideas from
from beta from Bayesian statistics to
build that model so we use the Gaussian
processes as a prior for performance
functions we have some kind of we have
some kind of likelihood model so usually
that's is usually have some kind of like
normal likelihood over over the values
of your performance function and then
you can use Bayes rule to iteratively
update you know your posterior
distribution I'm not going into too much
details of the mathematics behind that
but I do want to touch upon these
Gaussian processes because they I think
they're the quote quite a versatile tool
and it's good to have a little bit of an
idea of what these things are and how
they behave
because they they play a quite pivotal
role in this particular algorithm so how
you can think about Gaussian processes
is that they really are the
generalization of a Gaussian Gaussian
distribution or a normal distribution
but instead of over real numbers you
it's a generalization of that over-over
functions and a way and just like a a
normal variable is usually the it's
completely defined by its mean and by
its standard deviation a Gaussian
process is now
completely defined by its meaning
function and stem and its covariance
function and a way to think about these
Gaussian processes is that instead of of
you know the normal distribution giving
you a real number back a scalar number
back now the Gaussian process gives you
the mean for navigation both now the
Gaussian process for any any point of
your performance function it gives you
back the mean and standard deviation of
another random this another normal
distribution at that point I realize
this is a you know quite a lot of you
just charged s so I put this plot here
in a hopes that this sort of makes this
idea a little bit more clear so if you
if you've already you've already dealt
with motion poses in the past you may
have seen this picture before but this
really shows shows what I just what I
was just talking about that the Gaussian
process now returns it's a function that
at any point returns the mean and
standard deviation of a normal
distribution at that point so how should
you read this picture right so what we
have here is we have the solid dark line
here this is basically the function
we're trying to optimize or maximize or
minimize whatever you're trying to do so
in our concepts you could think of it as
our performance function perhaps the the
blue shaded region is the probability
model that that we're building using the
Gaussian proceeds so what we're seeing
is you know at the point where we in the
the dark circles you know the actual
points that we have evaluated so you can
see okay where we evaluated the function
we are actually quite certain about you
know what to tell you actually is there
but in regions where we haven't
evaluates anything so here and here we
are much more uncertain about what's
going on which makes sense right like we
haven't evaluated in that region so we
don't know what's going on so what does
the Gaussian process do so if you look
at this point for example it says okay
at this point the the values of our
performance function they follow a
normal distribution with the meaning
given by this which is given by the
Gaussian process and a standard
deviation given by this so every point
like here here and
here you can build a normal distribution
over the potential values of the
performance function at that point so
and this is how these Gaussian processes
model the the performance function does
this make sense is this because it's all
a you know I'm not sure I'm trying not
to show any formulas here and for people
with math from Saturday morning but I
really want to build up the intuition so
you have a kind of like a general idea
of how the how these things work because
the math behind it can actually get
quite involved it's very interesting
software but seems to involve four top
right now so that was sort of the first
component operation optimization
algorithm right so remember we have
these three sort of steps in our
algorithm we just talked about how we
build the probability model which which
is how we do it
so we but yeah which is which we do
we'll go through processes so now the
next question is okay how do we actually
a given a probability model given our
current believe the power of a
performance function how do you actually
choose a new point so you can again you
can see it you can think about this
setting or the - green line is for
performance function we have a
probability model we have some
evaluation points and the question here
now is okay
how yeah where am I going to sample next
I'm going to stick to this minimum or
I've found out what we're trying to do
here by the way is minimizing this
function we're going to stick to this
region or we're going to explore the
unexplored regions so how do we do this
we try to use utility functions and in
the context of Bayesian algorithms they
are usually called acquisition functions
and they they for they've sort of
formalized in mathematical way what
constitutes what's what is the next best
guess there are a lot of lots of
different acquisition functions actually
I just want to talk about one in
particular which is called the expected
improvement acquisition function and
what it does is what it tries to do is
say okay it wants for Mars okay let's
take the poor the next point should be
the point that in expectation is going
to maximize R is going to increase or
performance the most so if you look at
this thing this is again a performance
function this is
trying to maximize over and this is the
current optimum the latter the best
study we've found so far so we're really
trying to maximize that difference like
how much better can we get given our
current current optimum and the reason
why people look at the expected
improvement function is because given in
the illest setting given like the
gaussian process model you can actually
evaluate this thing analytically yeah
sorry because you don't want to because
you don't really want to look at the
negative things you really want to look
at the points where you're going to
increase pause where you're going to
decrease you're not really interested in
that right so cool so you can actually
valuate it like this and the reason why
I want to show you this is because it's
sort of built up it can help you to
build up some intuition around how this
acquisition function actually behaves
because if you look at this what you
want to do is we want to maximize the
expected improvement so we're going to
look at this function and think about
okay when is this function going to when
is the value of this function going to
be large or big or whatever well there
are sort of two ways where this can
happen one case is this term is going to
be large which basically means we we
want to sample a theta that we expect to
have a much higher value than a current
best value or we're going to sample in a
region where the uncertainty is very
high so this this is sometimes what's
called the exploration versus
exploitation trade-off so you want to
exploit a current region that's already
optimal or do you want to explore a
region where you don't really know
what's going on there because you
because you don't know what's going on
there it might very well be that there's
actually some kind of optimum value
there right so sometimes it's actually
worthwhile to look into that region so
if we go back to our earlier example
here this is our setting this is the
actual this is the expected improvement
acquisition function and can sort of see
that there are a couple of peaks here
one is to peak on the left one which
says okay hey on the left hand side
we've already find some kind of optimal
value so you know I expect to improve
there a lot if I just stay in that
region try to exploit that knowledge but
on the other hand you can also see that
on the right we have really sampled the
function there so the acquisition
function basically tells you that hey
there's also some value in exploring the
rest of your the domain of your function
yes yeah yes yeah yeah true but it's so
this is usually employed right so X is
the exit the high parameter space so
usually a kind of two bound that off
before you start this but which I think
it's generally a you always have this
kind of issue even with grid search
random search in general you sort of
have to take a this domain we're going
to look for four of them so this is how
it works so we use the Gaussian
processes to model the performance
function given our new belief we can
then use something like the expected
improvement function to say okay we
expect that this particular point will
improve our performance function the
most so let's switch kisses our new
theta and then we can just evaluate the
performance function for evening theta
and iterate and iterate update or model
again choose the next best value on and
on and on so this is how the the
bayesian optimization algorithm roughly
works so that's one that's one thing I
want to talk about right like how how
the actual algorithm works so now the
next questions again how can you
actually use can actually use this in
real life easy right like how easy is it
to archive smaller some data how is you
can I can actually use this so there are
two ways you can either use some
prepackaged module or you can try to
code it yourself so because I wanted to
get some better intuition of how this
actually works I tried to call it myself
and I think most of you are probably
familiar with with the machine learning
libraries I could learn and they
actually have a question as they've they
have a nice Gaussian process module in
there as well so you can use so I could
learn to actually implement this
specific algorithm so try to learn as
this Gaussian process module and the
next two the two agreed machine are
needed again you need to build the
actual the actual optimization routine
and the actual and you know the
performance function you want to want to
optimize so your performance function
could be something like this right you
have a loss function let's
you want to optimize the performance of
our support vector machine so the
support fox machine takes some
parameters let's say and our performance
function is actually the cross validated
a you see in this particular case so it
can it from working across the data to
performance measures and how hold out
performance measures you can make this
this is completely this can be a
completely black box function right it
could be a massive neural net as well
and then the second step is you know the
actual Bayesian optimization routine and
here again you see like the relative you
see I don't want to really simple but
straight yeah should clear API of this
sort of algorithm right you you have
your Gaussian process which is the
probability model of your function and
then we just the algorithms iterate what
we do is we fit we update our current
beliefs using it call them a little bit
then we want to sample the next we want
to determine the next best value so the
next feet are it's going to be this is
just a function that that optimizes that
takes the arc max to the of this
expected improvement acquisition
function and then you can sample the
loss and then iterate iterate and
iterate so if you do that so I've done
this for for the support vector machine
I've been talking about so the the top
plot is the expected improvement
function and the the lower plot is the
current the relatively current the
current belief of the performance
function actually so if you do this
iteratively let's see this works you can
see intuitively it tries to sample new
points so first it only has three points
right so it tries to explore the region
a little bit it explores the region a
little bit now we can see it's still
exploring and now you can see okay it's
starting to discover here this is an
optimal region here I actually get
really really good performance so you
can sort of see it's a it exposed a bit
first here here here and then it zooms
in on this on this optimal optimal
region of performance and I thought this
was quite cool actually like this to me
feels a lot nicer and well more ovate
then
like randomly sampling pointers hopes
for that hoping we win the lottery so
yeah so that's that that being said
though Gaussian processes like I was
when I was trying to talk like I was I
was really hoping to find something that
was just as simple to use as random as
random good choice Romano great search
right because let's be honest that's
also the appeal of these methods they're
just very very simple to use but but and
I was looking into it and the the plots
are you show you that's very
satisfactory it makes a lot of sense but
these methods are still very tricky so
you have to have two for one yes for one
you actually have to think about the
skill of your hyperparameters so this
meaning that if you have a learning rate
parameter for example or regularization
parameter for example you don't really
want to sample that on like uniform
domain you usually want to sample that
on like a LOC uniform domain because you
usually prefer that it's like 10 to the
power minus 5 minus 4 minus 3 minus 2 so
this is something you still deadly you
can't just throw in your problem into
this algorithm and hole and expect like
magic to happen right you still have to
think a little bit ok ok these are like
the specific hyperparameters I'm trying
to optimize for so I need to specify
that in the model and unlike us to this
question before you have to think about
the domain of your performance function
as well and then the other thing is the
the Gaussian process itself has a hyper
parameter the kernel so and actually the
behavior of this algorithm is very very
very dependent on the kernel of your of
your of your Gaussian process and
different kernels actually assume
different things so some kernels assume
things around different chevelle
different shareability of your I of your
performance function or periodicity of
your high off your performance function
so this is still something you you need
to think about so it's not it's I
thought I thought this was quite nice
you know quite a nice algorithm but
still you have to think about how to
basically to your performance function
you still have to tune the algorithm
that Tunes the performance function so
it's still a little tricky problem
unfortunately now to wrap the to wrap
things up this last is my last slide
it's of course very very nice that you
can implement this yourself
allows you to really like understand the
algorithm and how it works I wouldn't
really recommend you doing that if you
really want to apply this in like some
kind of production setting so if you are
really interested in that then maybe
it's a good idea to look at some of the
open source packages that are available
on the web so things so practice
experiment I brought I brought our very
nice and written something relatively
straightforward to use packages that can
allow you to use use these kind of
methods in a robust way and again like
we talked about Bayesian optimization
algorithms so or model-based
optimization algorithms but you don't
necessarily have to assume some kind of
model on your functions as on your
performance function so there are also
methods like hypervenom smack that are
actually model free so the modeler
models in a model free way and that's it
thank you very much for listening and if
there are any questions please let me
know okay thanks for the dog we have
like more less ten minutes for questions
so I just so this seems to work well for
continuous variables yeah unfortunately
not all hyper parameters or continuous
very true very true so you can so this
exercise back to the point about the
kernel so you can actually use the
kernel of the Gaussian process to tell
okay this part of the is the input space
is a categorical this part of the input
space is continuous so this is a I think
and then what I've seen like if you if
you look on the web I've seen two ways
people deal with this is one if they try
to use it from the kernel but I know I
know there are some I think it's like
called hemming kernel or you can use use
this used to do this but I haven't done
this myself
and the other way which I found less I
find that it's the last satisfactory but
I guess it works is that you let the
algorithm proposal continuous value and
they use floor it or something like this
which is not I don't really like this
driver it's a way to do with this with
this stuff alternatively you can imagine
that this is a bayesian way but it's a
search space mm-hm maybe gradient search
or what have you any other model you can
maybe do a support vector machine that
try
to estimate the values yeah yeah very
very true which i think is actually what
high prop dots on the lippert so they
don't have a Bayesian model on the hood
they actually have something that's
based on random forests on the hood so
yes this is it's these kind of
algorithms the sequential model days
algorithms they are not limited to a
Bayesian way you can use anything to
build some kind of model actually which
is also quite cool I yet take it for the
talk the question is have a chance to
compare this Bayesian approach read them
approach for some non-trivial data set
and non trivial algorithm like a
Bayesian finds the same as a random
search or not and ii think it's just
pointed one of good things about random
search you can do it in parallel and i
imagine that you carry enough cannon to
this one in parallel yeah yeah okay so
i've not done as myself
it's my mower what i've done is just
really trying to understand how it works
and giving it back to you guys but of
course there's a lot of work like a
federal office where they actually do
this where the charge of benchmarked is
against a bunch of different
optimization algorithms as well as
random search I think what I found in
general is that if you compare it
against these other algorithms and
random just random search it tends to
before it tends to find the optimum in
less iterations which is a good thing
but then I've also read some criticisms
of Bayesian algorithms where they say
okay the nice thing about random
searches I can just paralyze it right so
let's just if you can paralyze random
search it might take more iteration to
get the optimum but computationally it
actually takes less time because I
paralyzed it because this is it this is
hard to paralyze right so I think this
is like an area of ongoing research
actually okay one I can't make this run
quicker or can you paralyze it because
from what I read I think I read a paper
where they benchmark it against a pair
of running random search three times and
then you can actually see that the
renders it can be quicker so yeah again
I think it's a trade-off and I think
it's something that's on go there's a
lot of I think research into that into
that area at the moment
hope you dance question
hello thanks for the talk my question is
how well does this algorithm cope with
randomness turning time so so randomness
or training time for example ting random
forests where for similar hybrid
parameters for small data that you can
get very different results just based on
the randomness of the training mm-hmm so
the particular algorithm I've talked
about now it doesn't right it doesn't
take into account at all how long it
actually takes to calculate the value of
the performance functions but again
there's research into this area so I've
read a paper where they sort of
reformulate I think they reformate
second sorry okay so good yeah
I see sese I don't think it takes into
account I think that's very tricky
problem anyways right because if your
model is that sensitive to something I
can see it means your data is and you
have not a lot of data or your data is
very very message or it's very in
general I think it's a very hard problem
so this is not magically going to solve
it or fortunately for you I think that
that's not that's my answer I think you
can in systems like this we expanded
into a dynamic search it does like the
reinforcement learning for instance are
you aware of any attempts to use this
method in that direction good question I
think there are I don't know about a say
I think I think I I think I read
something around this is in connection
with like a multi-armed bandit but I
don't know enough about it to actually
answer the question I might have some
that your legs to literature for you
well I think I read it somewhere so if
you're really interested in that I can
I'm sure I can look it up for you
hi there you mentioned that the kernel
and choice is important or only need to
be tuned depending on the loss function
yeah if you had say a cold class of loss
functions you wanted to minimize over
every single one of those they had a
whole set of problems and you knew that
loss functions were in some way similar
yes so in their periodicity or in their
characteristics could you could this
automatically and go to Train on a set
of loss functions you pick the optimal
kernel that then be applied to the
out-of-sample loss functions all right
take a question I mean this is not
restricted to univariate functions right
so the I think the output of your
performance function could be
multi-dimensional so I guess you could
use this definitely to try and optimize
well it's hot it's hard right because
what's that what's the optimal value in
a multi-dimensional multi-dimensional
space like if you have a
multi-dimensional output I mean I don't
know I don't know I think it's
interesting question but I don't think I
can give you the answer to that question
actually okay so basically you have to
make some sort of sumption about the
optimal kernel I think I e s you
definitely have to like unfortunately
yes you do have to specify this as well
and maybe maybe in some method where you
can try to optimize the Ticuna but and I
think you need the kernel for the
optimizer that optimizes rigor and also
then you're sort of back at square one
right so I do think this is like fit
yeah you're the problem you can avoid
unfortunately no free lunch okay thank
you very much yeah
you have more questions okay if not
let's thank you speak again yeah
[Applause]
[Music]